[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en Francia 24
Bienvenidos a África 7 días comenzamos
con los titulares el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos Anthony blinken
finalizó su gira por África el
funcionario estadounidense buscaba
reforzar las relaciones diplomáticas y
económicas con el continente donde crece
la influencia de Rusia y de China vamos
al norte de gabón donde los bosques de
banglares están amenazados y podrían
desaparecer y con ellos la pesca
artesanal la causa es el aumento de los
proyectos inmobiliarios en la zona y
terminamos esta edición en agradedes la
ciudad más importante del norte de níger
asistimos a las fiestas de vianu un
festival cultural y religioso de música
y de danza
comenzamos con el viaje oficial del
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony blinken por tres países del
continente africano entre sus objetivos
el funcionario estadounidense Busca
reforzar las relaciones diplomáticas y
comerciales con el continente y sobre
todo hacer frente a la creciente
influencia de Rusia y china en la región
Andrés de triviño con los detalles
un acercamiento al continente africano
Anthony liken secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos finalizó una gira por
tres países africanos Sudáfrica
República democrática del Congo y Ruanda
la visita fue vista por la opinión
pública como parte de una competencia
entre Rusia y China contra Estados
Unidos y las potencias occidentales por
el liderazgo del mercado en África y el
apoyo a Ucrania tras su invasión el
líder de la diplomacia estadounidense
negó estos señalamientos
lo que más buscamos es verdadera
asociación entre Estados Unidos y África
no queremos una relación desequilibrada
o transaccional y nuestro compromiso con
una asociación más fuerte con África no
se trata de intentar superar a nadie
la visita de blinken le siguió los pasos
a su homólogo Ruso serguéi y al
presidente de Francia Emmanuel macrón
quienes realizaron una gira similar
recientemente buscando acercamientos y
afianzar posiciones por parte de los
gobiernos africanos los países de África
no se han opuesto a la invasión de
Ucrania y son los principales
compradores de granos y trigo a Rusia y
Ucrania alrededor del 40% de los granos
consumidos en el Continente vienen de la
zona en guerra la ONU estima que más de
40 millones de personas sufrirán de
inseguridad alimentaria por las acciones
de Putin a su país vecino
si un país decide comprometerse con
Rusia donde hay sanciones Entonces esta
incumpliendo esas acciones y en algunos
casos las sanciones de la ONU con otros
países advertimos a los países que no
inclinan esas sanciones porque tienen la
posibilidad de que se tomen medidas
contraídos
actualmente África vive un grave aumento
en los precios de los alimentos en parte
por la pandemia y las sanciones a la
exportación de granos rusos no hay nadie
en Sudáfrica que apoye la guerra lo
hemos dejado muy claro y hemos dicho que
deseamos ver intensificados los
esfuerzos para aumentar la diplomacia en
cuanto a los negocios china es el
principal socio comercial de África el
gigante asiático invirtió más de 47 mil
millones de dólares en 2020 y estima que
para el 2035 sean 60.000
por su parte blinken dijo que inició un
nuevo capítulo en las relaciones entre
Estados Unidos y el continente africano
con una nueva estrategia anunciada
durante su giro África es el futuro y
Washington va a invertir en él dijo link
en antes de abandonar el continente
africano
cambiamos de tema y vamos a Sierra Leona
las protestas contra el costo de la vida
en este país de África occidental se
convirtieron en disturbios en la capital
free Town Dos policías murieron y el
vicepresidente Mohamed schul de chalo
anunció un toque de queda varios
manifestantes también afirmaron a la
prensa que las fuerzas de seguridad
habían disparado contra ellos
información corroborada por los
testimonios de las autoridades de los
diferentes hospitales a los que fueron
trasladados los heridos a pesar de su
suelo rico en diamantes Sierra Leona es
uno de los países menos desarrollados
del mundo el presidente
juliusmada dio introdujo el primero de
julio nuevas monedas y billetes en un
intento de restaurar la confianza en
medio de la elevada inflación los 7,5
millones de habitantes de esta antigua
Colonia británica Aún se están
recuperando de una brutal Guerra Civil
entre 1991 y 2002 y del brote de ébola
de 2014 a 2016
guisobro te afectó la región de África
occidental posteriormente el país se dio
afectado por la pandemia del 19 y las
consecuencias de la guerra en Ucrania
más de 70 hectáreas en los últimos tres
años los manglares del norte de gabón
están perdiendo terreno ante el aumento
de proyectos inmobiliarios para el
desarrollo de nuevas zonas residenciales
y hoteleras en consecuencia la economía
local que se basa esencialmente en la
pesca se encuentra en peligro
20 kilómetros al norte de la capital de
gabón lifoville en el pequeño pueblo de
capisteria en medio de los manglares y
aní su hermano recogen las trampas para
cangrejos que colocaron el día anterior
hay un buen cangrejo No aquí los
habitantes viven principalmente de la
pesca artesanal una actividad que ahora
está en peligro por la presión
inmobiliaria que está destruyendo el
ecosistema donde se reproducen los
crustáceos
antes incluso detrás de la casa Si
ponías 15 cajas en menos de una hora se
llenaban pero hoy como ves todo está
despejado Incluso si dejas 20 cajas te
vas todo el día resuelves no habrá
cangrejos porque el sol da en las cajas
el manglar ya no está ante la
desaparición del manglar los voluntarios
de las ong como laundry llevan a cabo
vastas campañas de reforestación se
encuentran en la orilla este del
estuario debajo de los mangles buscan
semillas que plantarán para que el
manglar vuelva a crecer y se salve en
sus mariscos
Por qué queremos reforestar en primer
lugar a nivel económico se trata de
limitar la Urbanización anárquica de
limitar la especulación inmobiliaria que
se extienda a lo largo de varios
kilómetros
pero también a nivel medioambiental
queremos permitir la reproducción de las
especies que dependen de este manglar
ante la desaparición de este rico
ecosistema las autoridades gabonesas
están reforzando las medidas para
obligar a los promotores los comentarios
a realizar estudios de impacto ambiental
antes de construir cerca de los
manglares
tenemos una brigada que se ha creado
aquí y hoy el apoyo de las ongs permite
alertar a mucha gente y seguimos
generando conciencia también tomamos una
serie de medidas con respecto a ciertas
personas que reinciden y no respetan los
requerimientos que se les hacen
a pesar de estas disposiciones legales
el litoral gabonés Sigue perdiendo sus
manglares Aunque el código
medioambiental y en particular el
artículo 64 prohíbe la construcción de
edificios en lugares naturales sensibles
o cerca de la costa
Hablamos ahora de tecnología los
gigantes de los idiomas Google Translate
y duolingo incluyeron dentro de sus
plataformas lenguas nativas africanas
con esta iniciativa se busca que más
personas tengan acceso a idiomas poco
difundidos y que no tienen una presencia
destacada en internet un informe de
Andrés Treviño
los idiomas nativos africanos ahora
podrán ser traducidos de forma inmediata
Hello
usal nació en India pero creció en
campana la capital de uganda donde luchó
durante mucho tiempo para comprender
luganda uno de los idiomas hablados en
el país africano a pesar de que lo
hablan más de 21 millones de personas en
todo el está africano no está disponible
en internet para su traducción ni
enseñanza hasta ahora
tenemos lugar en diccionarios que están
en las librerías y cosas por el estilo
Pero hay muy pocos recursos en internet
hay algunos manuales y materiales en
línea para aprender luganda pero ahora
hay una aplicación o servicio de
traducción adecuado que podemos usar Así
que es increíble
celebra las nuevas funciones de Google y
duolingo compañías que vieron la
necesidad de expandir su base
lingüística para cualquier persona en el
mundo con acceso a internet luganda es
una de las 23 lenguas nativas africanas
agregadas a Google recientemente Aunque
es un avance tan solo representa el 17%
del total de las 2.000 Lenguas que
alberga el continente casi donde quiera
que vayas en uganda la gente conoce el
uganda aquellos que no lo hablan pueden
escucharlo y pueden entenderlo que
realmente quieres decir
la nueva característica de Google y
duolingo es parte de un impulso para
ampliar la representación y reducir el
sesgo en los sistemas de Inteligencia
artificial
un enfoque monolingüe utilizaron el
aprendizaje automático y la Inteligencia
artificial para hacer uso de todos estos
datos Y luego crear estos modelos que
ayudan con la traducción de estos
idiomas que no tienen mucho material en
línea
[Música]
online
aspirante a políglota ahora puede
estudiar directamente en luganda
programadores de las compañías dijeron
que los hablantes de idiomas
minoritarios pueden sentir que el mundo
de la tecnología
está ignorando y esta estrategia intenta
cerrar esa Brecha
vamos ahora a níger en la ciudad de
agades la más importante del Norte del
país donde pese a la creciente
inseguridad por la violencia yadista se
celebra el Villano una tradición de la
comunidad Tuareg del país los tuaregs
son un pueblo de tradición nómada del
desierto del Sahara y Elvia no es una
fiesta cultural y religiosa que requiere
varios días de preparación la festividad
es la conmemoración de la bienvenida que
el pueblo de Medina en Arabia Saudita le
dio al profeta del islam Mahoma o
muhammad en árabe tras las victorias de
Las Guerras Santas veamos el informe de
haroldt
[Música]
pasaron la noche en el desierto del
Sahara estos hombres son los bailarines
del vianú el evento religioso y cultural
más importante de la ciudad nigerina de
acadez
nosotros mismos tenemos las prendas pero
la tela y el tinte vienen de Nigeria
todo lo demás se hace aquí estas prendas
suelen costar más de 500 dólares pero
hoy tenemos dificultades con las
importaciones por la inseguridad es muy
complicado traer productos de esta
Nigeria antes del terrorismo y de la
inseguridad el festival vianu atraía a
gente de fuera del continente africano
hoy es una celebración más confidencial
pero muy viva como antes de una batalla
aquí todo el mundo se prepara jóvenes
ancianos mujeres todos se visten al
ritmo del tambor al mediodía la fiesta
está en su apogeo bajo 40 grados pero
tras el recrudecimiento de la violencia
Armada en níger algunos temores
permanecen Estamos de fiesta y felices
Lo único que quiero es no tener
problemas hasta el final del día todos
los desfiles de la fiesta de viannú se
detienen frente al palacio del Sultán
cada uno baila a su manera la hermandad
pero también la inclusión del otro del
extranjero se celebran
Ese es el festival de vida No todo lo
que tienes que hacer es llevar un
turbante como este
serás considerado como uno de nosotros
no te quedas fuera Esto es lo que
fortalece la unidad nacional haga es un
centro es un símbolo una escuela de cómo
construir la unidad nacional
solo unos días de celebración y el
biance evapora de nuevo en el Sáhara
después de haber dado la paz que pudo en
un ambiente agitado
así termina la edición de esta semana
gracias por su sintonía la actualidad
internacional continúa en Francia 24.com
[Música]